ah enough okay okay I get the point how
do I turn this off ah hmm
the Melanie's loop is pretty comfy
actually let me check my schedule for
the day oops
tooth paste this is Johnny Ives worst
nightmare
yeah Apple says don't do this
but come on Twitter in the shower
what no reminder to wash behind my ears
and weather check window says umbrella
Apple watch confirms need caffeine now
oh good
Ryan can meet today Siri at a meeting
with Brian today at 3:00 talking to your
wrist is weird but weirdly helpful this
feels old-fashioned well I guess I know
Jeff is alive because his heart is
beating on my wrist hmm the only
appropriate way to respond with a random
I'm hand seriously who approved this
another day another dollar hmm maybe
I'll check the headlines no not that app
what is this an interface for people
with doll hands and why are there so
many menus
so many notifications there's no way I'm
standing up right now I don't know I
mean you know it's been tough lately she
one day she likes me one day she doesn't
like me I don't know it just it seemed
really gonna talk to me about this again
I wonder if he'll notice if I read some
email or some news or see what's
happening on Twitter
Joanna are you even listening to me
never touch these little things
oh hi mr. Murdoch I said the Apple watch
it is can I try sure yeah that's okay
that's really nice yeah thank you very
much thank you Oh actually I need that
back nice I don't have to go digging in
my purse for my phone Wow but I finally
got my Apple watch oh I'm gonna be late
for my spinning class again and I still
need to change my clothes and my watch
band okay so I popped this off now
here's the sports band okay this is
really not that easy or fast how many
calories did that burn Apple watch
okay exercise app let's see what you got
not a bad start heart rate at 120 to 150
two beats per minute that's really
accurate hey front row she talking to me
on a ride that's really embarrassing
and my entire workout is now synced to
the phone almost 250 calories burned
nice I'm so hungry these are so good and
now I just DoubleTap on here and
awkwardly hold my wrist up to this and
it works okay that's pretty cool
especially since you don't even need to
have your phone nearby must get home
must change must get ready for dinner
you know what would match the flowers on
these shoes a butterfly watch face well
even a $650 watch doesn't seem to get me
a
we're on time sorry I'm late and welcome
to power reserve mode Apple watch is
down for the count
I've still got some juice left oh well
that was a day huh Apple watch you want
to do a lot of things in my life
sometimes you're helpful other times
you're way too complicated frustrating
and slow
good night Apple watch there's always
tomorrow or version two